c'était peut-être reconnaître certaines
drogues dans ses croquis est notre
invité à billets les plus grandes
je veux dire grande parce que c'est pas
mal des robes que vous allez voir des
grandes artistes et participer aux
spectacles les plus marquants couturier
d asnières créateurs costumes pour la
scène musicale théâtrale télévisuelle
également au québec depuis 45 ans le
centre d'art diane dufresne présente ses
oeuvres jusqu'au 17 février était avec
nous sur vidas bonjour bonjour merci des
classes matin vos créations étaient
portés par de grandes québécoise on
pense à diane dufresne céline dion julie
snyder michel richer entre autres
exposez vos costumes comme ça vaut aux
arbres c'est une façon de raconter ce
qui le processus créatif exactement oui
tout à fait c'est une rétrospective
parce que je commence avec les dessins
où j'étais à l'école de dessin à l'école
des métiers commerciaux et on va jusqu'à
la dernière production que je viens de
finir qui s'appelle tanguy où j'ai
dessiné pour france castel des costumes
alors c'est vraiment complet cette fois
ci on voit tout ce que j'ai dessiné si
on retourne aux premiers croquis
qu'est ce qui vous a amené à dessiner
les costumes
au départ c'était ma passion quand
j'étais adolescent c'était plutôt la
littérature la peinture je pensais
devenir prof en fait et vers 17 18 ans
j'ai eu un goût pour l'intérieur goût
pour la mode
alors j'ai décidé d'aller étudier à
l'école des métiers commerciaux qui
donnait s'écoule et ce goût là ce désir
là pour la mode s'est transformée
tranquillement au départ vers les
costumes parce que j'aimais beaucoup les
costumes de scène les costumes de
télévision entre autres mais je
commençais à radio-canada évidemment oui
c'est ça je me 74 96 exactement
bon alors vous avez dessiné toutes
sortes de robe iny
gina certainement d'autres qui ont passé
également à d'histoire pour parler nous
par exemple de cette robe qui a fait
l'eurovision
oui assez pour céline j'avais commencé à
travailler avec céline à radio canada
dans le cadre d'une émission qui
s'appelle incognito qui s'appelait
incognito et qui servait à faire la
promotion du disque que les civils qui
venait d'être lancé alors c'est à dire
que porter céline aérovision oui c'est
exactement celle robidas oui et vous
avez été responsable d'un peu de cécile
en a environ la formation des
apparitions tv le lancement de son
disque eurovision en trop présentation à
ronald reagan dont voici rebelote dans
l'exposition
est-ce que ça a été difficile de faire
une sélection des pièces pour cette
brève à faire je dois beaucoup aux
grands costumier qui a récupéré le stock
de radio canada parce que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé ici au cirque du soleil est
aussi aux artistes qui m'ont prêté je
pensais julie je pense une charge à tous
ces artistes là me prêtent leurs
costumes pour l'exposition un parler de
julie je lis nous nommer nous une des
oeuvres que vous avez fait pour l as
extravagante que je pense à la tour
eiffel
moi je veux jouer à paris ça c'était le
premier spectacle à paris alors j'avais
fait une robe tour eiffel dans l'esprit
de julie son humour évidemment c'était
lalique la tour eiffel était illuminée
pour la première fois donc on a
reproduit le scintillement dans la raab
et c'était l'année 2000 donc l'année des
grands feux d'artifice qui avait eu lieu
sur le tour est fait vous avez quelqu'un
robe assez spectaculaire pasqua qui
était confortable ça auquel est très
lourde en général ça prend des femmes
qui ont une force de caractère et une
force physique que c'est si une femme
qui a une force de caractère et qui
avait vraiment quand même la force de
porter la robe théâtre scénarios
différents et la robe ses fans écossais
qui est arrivé après c'est des robes en
fait des robes architecture je pourrais
dire parce que je travaille en
scénographie aussi donc jeté comme
souvent à cause de mes robes dans l'est
dans les ateliers de décors lareau
perdre on la voit ça on peut la vendre
dans l'exposition
comment vous est venue l'idée de faire
une pièce aussi énorme c'est quand même
oui en fait c'est un hasard à la réunion
de production avec rené richard cyr
on écrit diane train dit je vous donne
robe rouge enveloppes se mêle au rideau
du théâtre
moi j'écris dans mes notes robe trait
d'union théâtre et à ce moment là le
soir je relis mina et l'image m'arrive
le flash par mégarde la robe pourrait
être un théâtre
je téléphonais diam qui me disait bella
commence à faire sa cave en surface
j'ai dit le point c'est pas ça est ce
que ça te servir et que ta gueule soit
interne
quand on dit oui puis on a commencé ce
soit je le quittais soir ça va bien au
delà de quelques d'habiller l'artiste
lol ça c'est carrément le spectacle est
ce que c'est votre oeuvre la plus
importante
j'ai fait des choses même assez
récemment avec deux gîtes marchande où
je t'aime où j'ai fait une robe
qui était immense dans lequel il y avait
des musiciens avec quatuor à cordes et
la robe s'ouvre est hélas devenu le
décor c'était à l'oratoire saint joseph
donc en termes d'importance que j'ai
fait aussi au soleil en europe qui avait
80 pieds de longueur et qu'ils étaient
manipulés par des acrobates des
acrobates la robe s'élever dans les airs
puis les acrobates montel avoir bien
envoyé des numéros de cirque qu'est ce
qui vous motive qui nourrit votre
inspiration pour en arriver à des
oeuvres aussi imposante
ben moi je fais quand j'ai fait ce
métier là c'était surtout pour amener de
la magie chez les gens de les étonner
les surprendre les faire sourire aussi
soft important et je c'était ça c'est le
côté un peu fantastique qu'on ose se
pose souvent extrêmes et je pense que
les gens adorent le fantastique
oui est ce que ça donne tout un coup
d'oeil tout un spectacle et chose
certaine ce sont des pièces uniques 1
oui parce que sa commandite thalassa pas
là toujours être très convaincant mami
chan
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous en
rappelle dans cette exposition au centre
d'art diane dufresne jusqu'au 17 février
on peut aller voir vos oeuvres et voir
un peu les croquis l'histoire derrière
merci